get in these arms nice to see you I'm
gonna put you right on this okay I'm
gonna direct you
so we go way back you know
yeah moderating panels for us and always
been yeah yeah yeah yeah even even
before I was around you've been you've
been part of the Star Wars world I know
but you really
I mean I feel like I I I'll start crying
if I talk too much about it but I credit
you with a lot of my I've always been
the best always ask great questions and
you all you also know what the fans want
because you are one and uh no it's
always it's always nice to have that to
be invited into the world you know you
had a really good thing going already
with the Star Wars and with Dave filoni
so um now thanks for all the support and
everything we're able to enjoy now a lot
of it was was uh thanks to thanks to
your support and introducing us to the
world
learning about how to fight
you also have to know how to navigate
the Galaxy
oh last season where we left off well
actually in book a Boba Fett grogu
elects not to train with Luke
it's kind of like some people train when
they're older grogu's 50 how does this
affect him that now that he's not
actively training how will it affect his
Force Power well you know Luke also left
his uh teach teacher for to be with his
friends and help out in something bigger
so uh I think we've learned from Star
Wars and what George Lucas established
that that if you have a certain
Foundation just like martial arts or a
lot of other skills you could continue
to train on your own or maybe seek out
other teachers but he's also going to
get together with um within John with
the Mandalorian and there's a lot he has
to learn from that world too different
lessons about the lessons of being in a
Mandalorian so it'll be interesting to
see how that combination of uh of
mentors affects the way he develops as a
character John if you put a little Mando
helmet on him I will
lose my damn mind
if you do that okay so a thing came out
today where people were like wow more
time has gone through in this show than
I think we expected so we meet grogo
he's 50-ish do you know how old he is
now at the start of this we talk about
it I hate to put a number on it because
I'm sure when we get back to Dave's
office and look on the Whiteboard and
start working out all the math just how
the math has to cross over with other
shows too with Ahsoka and skeleton crew
we have to work it all out and figure
out how it fits in the larger context
but basically assume it's close to real
time for the time we spent with them on
the show and now we've spent two years
apart from these two characters and
they've been separated for for quite
some time and then they've got together
as you point out a few episodes of The
Book of Boba Fett we checked in and now
we're meeting them and there's been some
progression but there are a lot of
unresolved issues especially for the
Mandalorian as he has taken his helmet
off and no longer is considered a part
of that faction that he was a part of I
have a theory but I'm not going to say
it out loud because I always get myself
in trouble I keep hearing the word
culmination you guys obviously have all
of these shows coming what can you talk
like what can you tease about that are
you leading to something you obviously
started the MCU so what are you building
well well things certainly will
culminate uh this season because there's
a lot of characters that we've set up
and they're all a lot of them are coming
together again there are bigger things
happening in the Galaxy as well we have
the resurgent Empire and we have the
mandalorians who are scattered and
there's lots of different factions that
are uh all over the Galaxy and uh but by
the same token we really are we're
enjoying leaning into what inspired
George Lucas originally which was like
The Flash Gordon serialized uh science
fiction stories so while we're resolving
characters and story lines and things
changed and adjusts we want to keep the
story going and we know that we have a
certain amount of time in Star Wars
story that we have a lot of freedom and
there's also things that we want to play
with and set up that are reflecting what
uh has existed before what we're doing
here I remember when I interviewed you
for season one you were like I'm already
thinking of Season Two Season Two you're
like I'm already singing
you said you've already written season
four how much how much further do you
think the Mandalorian story is going to
go there are a lot of it's up to the
audience to be honest with you uh
there's plenty of room for development
for these characters and we've
established a really interesting Dynamic
and room for growth uh there's a lot of
things happening uh outside of these
characters that will affect things and
uh there are characters that are uh on
the horizon that are uh going to enter
going to uh and you know take the stage
there's other characters other ones we
don't know about yeah there's a lot of
and we're constantly thinking about
where this can go and how this can play
out and how all these pieces can fit
together so it's like a big puzzle but
at the end of the day it's about people
and about relationships and about uh
training and growth and that's uh that's
what you know that that's the template
that George laid out and we try to
Aspire to those same principles
this is awesome thank you so much John
always a pleasure always a pleasure so
good to see you thank you
foreign